[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue à tous dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires sur tv5monde et sur vos
chaînes locales et régionales tout de
suite voici les titres de l'accueil
dans ce journal vous verrez comment
nouvelle aquitaine on ne mégote pas sur
la prévention contre le tabagisme des
femmes enceintes un reportage à suivre
de télé7 la chaîne du groupe sud ouest
alors que le nucléaire est au coeur de
tous les débats une équipe de wéo tv la
chaîne de la voix du nord et à l'est
allant rencontrer des producteurs de
biogaz pour verrait son reportage dans
un instant et puis dans ce journal on
montrera grâce à nos confrères de la
dépêche du midi comment les seniors
peuvent continuer à voyager tout en
restant bien installé confortablement
dans leurs fauteuils
enfin pour ceux qui se seraient fait la
promesse en ce début d'année de
reprendre la pratique d'un sport à la
fin de ce journal 8 mont blanc vous en
fera découvrir un accessible aux plus
réfractaires vous allez voir voilà on
démarre ce journal avec toujours et
encore la cigarette on ne le répétera
jamais assez c'est un véritable fléau
plus particulièrement d'ailleurs chez
les femmes enceintes les chiffres du
ministère de la santé ne trompent pas 17
8 % d'entre elles fument toujours au
troisième trimestre de leur grossesse ce
chiffre passe à 20 pont sans nouvelles
aquitaine où un dispositif a été mis en
place il y un peu moins d'un an il faut
bien le dire il doit être efficace il
al'obligation de l'être explication
d'arcachon de florian sabatier de télé7
la chaîne du groupe sud ouest
au centre hospitalier d'arcachon un
projet de recherche a été mise en place
en février 2020 sur le sevrage tabagique
des femmes enceintes près de 240 mille
femmes de la région de nouvelles
aquitaine à couches dont 20% sont des
fumeuses jusqu alors les professionnels
de santé nhs interrogé pas leurs
patientes sur leur statut tabagique avec
le projet 5a qui tels les professionnels
de santé sont plus à même de demander si
leur patient fume et de les aider à
arrêter tout en évaluant leur situation
pas à pas pour le professeur françois là
cet outil est un vrai plus pour tous
pour les acteurs de la santé mais aussi
les femmes enceintes ce que tous les
professionnels et à disposition les
ressources cas dans leurs territoires
qui peuvent mobiliser au service des
femmes enceintes et qu'on s'assure
ensuite de l'effectif et du suivi de ces
femmes au cours de la grossesse et c'est
ce que nous avons testé sur le
territoire d'arcachon avec de très bons
résultats 25% de fumée en moins au cours
d'autres expérimentations en 2020 début
2021 et nous espérons le mettre en
oeuvre dans toute la nouvelle aquitaine
en france la consommation tabagique est
très importante vis-à-vis de nos voisins
européens
plus précisément la nouvelle aquitaine
est la troisième région de l'hexagone
qui fume le plus grâce à ce suivi plus
personnalisé des fumeuses ont réduit
considérablement les délais de
consultation pour les aides pour marion
le fait cette méthode 5 aquitaine permet
de suivre l'évolution des patientes
avant pendant et après la grossesse je
trouve que les résultats sont plutôt
encourageants et jespere que sava
tendent à se pérenniser davantage pour
la rechute est très fréquentée fait
partie de la maladie puisque ça reste
une pathologies addictives et la rechute
fait partie du processus donc oui ça
arrive fréquemment le tout c'est qu'elle
soit capable après de rebondir et de
revenir me voir et c'est déjà arrivé à
l'aide de cette méthode les résultats
prometteurs du centre hospitalier
d'arcachon ont donné l'idée de réaliser
les 5 ha dans l'ensemble des maternités
de la région nouvelle aquitaine qui a
rappelons le le tabagisme passif des
enfants peut accélérer le potentiel de
diabète d'obésité ou encore d'accident
vasculaire cérébral
comme je vous le disais dans les titres
de ce journal il se peut que vous ayez
entendu déjà parlé du biogaz ce gaz
écologique produit à partir de la
méthanisation de matières organiques des
céréales par exemple ou même des bouses
de vache explications près de laon dans
les hauts de france avec jérôme houbron
de la chaîne wéo la chaîne de la voix du
nord
henri leconte est agriculteur près de
laon non loin de son exploitation il a
développé il y a un nom une nouvelle
activité la production de biogaz ça ce
sont des issues de céréales en
l'occurrence des follicules de maïs
c'est un coproduit qui qui provient de
la production de céréales que nous
faisons sur nos exploitations agricoles
donc c'est la matière organiques
végétales qui est ensuite introduite
dans le méthaniseur pour produire du
biogaz cette unité de biométhane fait
partie des cinquante et une présentant
haute france chaque heure elle produit
20 gigawatts de biogaz traités sur place
via ce poste d'injection
de quoi alimenter en énergie verte près
de 1700 foyers des communes alentour et
certains véhicules réduisant de 80 %
leurs émissions de co2 ce poste avant
injection de ce gaz vers dans le réseau
permet de le contrôler en permanence de
l'autoriser puisque c'est une obligation
réglementaire mais aussi de leur comté
et surtout d'en assurer la régulation
c'est à dire que ce biogaz ce bio
méthane est prioritaire sur le gaz
naturel qui circulent sur l'ensemble du
réseau des pommes de terre non
commercialisé fournis par la grande
distribution de la pulpe de betterave ou
encore des intrants issus de cultures
intermédiaires pour produire cette
énergie henri leconte incorpore dans ses
cuves 60 tonnes de matières organiques
végétales si la plantation d'un tel
dispositif parfois subir les critiques
de la part des riverains pour
l'agriculteur la méthanisation est un
cercle vertueux nous alimentons la
population qui est notre métier première
nous captons du carbone nous produisons
de l'énergie est en fin de cycle nous
pouvons et pendre le digestat don qui
est un coproduit de la méthanisation
c'est un engrais 100 % naturel et
locales qui est réintroduit sur nos
parcelles agricoles pour les fertiliser
selon une étude de grdf 80% des
habitants des hautes france seraient
prêts à consommer le gaz issus d'unités
de méthanisation
mais le sujet reste sensible
la majorité des projet de méthaniseur
font aujourd'hui face à l'hostilité des
riverains
voilà nous partons maintenant pour les
antilles à saint pierre en martinique
faire la connaissance de grégory assad
c'est un talentueux stylistes qui est
promis vous allez le voir un bel avenir
tom gagnon de via la tv l'a rencontré
dans ses ateliers sur place
une première collection présentée à
paris en juin dernier trente quatre
looks différents pour plus de 100 pièces
vêtements accessoires chaussures à
seulement 22 ans grégory à ça déborde
d'énergie et surtout d'idées en fait je
vis non on va dire l'accessoire avec des
matières lieux qui sont pas forcément
utilisés pour faire des sacs là on a en
fait de près ce type de sacs qui sont
comme des bonnes en fait des clottes
donc du coup qui sont de postiches un
nom de dévoilement de mariée de
cérémonie en fait que j'ai accumulé
parce qu'ils sont symétriques donc j'ai
pris le même c'est dans cet atelier
niché à saint pierre que le jeune
créateur se réfugie lorsqu'il n'est pas
à paris ici avec l'aide de plusieurs
couturière il planche sur ses futurs
projets confectionne des pièces uniques
mais au fait c'est quoi le style assad
donc c'est quelque chose de très
personnel donc je pense que le mot
personnel fait important dans cette
réponse parce que c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui m'est propre c'est à dire que
je puise dans ce que moi j'ai vécu dans
mes origines dans les archives de mon
pays et autres que je vais mixer avec
autre chose qui n'est pas forcément
affiliés afin les couleurs les tissus
les formes mais aussi des époques et des
thématiques singulière pour réinventer
la mode on a énormément de richesse ici
en martinique surtout par rapport aux
madras par exemple qui est l'un des
exemples phares qu'on peut citer cons et
qu'on retrouve dans mon travail après
oui j'aime beaucoup les années 70
certains photographes que j'aime
énormément comme notamment malick sidibé
qui a essentiellement novice début de
collection avec ses portraits en noir et
blanc
le styliste ne s'accorde aucun moment de
répit il prépare d'ores et déjà un
nouveau projet sur un thème qu'il
préfère garder secret la prochaine fois
il aimerait faire le défilé sur ses
terres natales en martinique
tout à fait autre chose dans l'actualité
pour améliorer la mémoire et la capacité
d'attention rien ne vaut une bonne
petite partie d'échecs jeu qui a connu
un regain d'intérêt avec le succès sans
précédent de la série le jeu de la dame
diffusée sur netflix et bien l'école
élémentaire marcel pagnol à coignières
dans les yvelines a elle décidé de
joindre l'utile à l'agréable en
proposant des cours d'échecs à des
élèves de cm2 auquel céline charles de
tv 78 a tendu son micro
entraîné par le joueur et animateur
diplômé de la fédération française des
échecs claude chiron ses élèves de cm2
ça donne une fois par semaine un cours
un peu originale des parties d'échecs
après une présentation théorique sur un
échiquier murale les élèves se lancent
en duo une initiative qui semble plaire
à ses enfants et j'adore cgt pense que
je les fais depuis que je suis toute
toute petite j'ai géré mon grand-père
j'adore mais parfois quand je sais pas
quoi faire
parce que j aime pas trop perdre c'est
très important de faire ce genre de jeu
surtout qu'ils ne sont plus habitués à
jouer
enfin moins habitués à jouer à des jeux
de société et surtout des jeux de
société de ce niveau qui sont vraiment
complexe un jeu qui possède de nombreux
bénéfices il invite les élèves à la
réflexion la stratégie ou encore la
mémorisation c'est un jeu des stratégies
et aussi ses des réflexions tu dois
réfléchir avant de jouer et du coup ça
t'aide aussi dans dans les devoirs
trouve on s'amuse beaucoup avec nos amis
au japon joue ensemble
démissionner ça nous aide à réfléchir à
nous concentrer certains élèves sur
trend victor peut selon ses camarades
faire un échec et mat en quatre coups
dit le coup du berger espoirs de la
classe il est souvent sollicité par
l'animateur pour enseigner aux autres il
a vraiment un à caution qui lui permet
donc de d'apprendre aux autres élèves et
je compte sur lui parce que ce garçon et
met déjà dans cette activité pour
montreuil où le 22 mars prochain les
élèves raconteront à domicile les
champions de france sortants lors du
championnat scolaire académique d'échec
voilà dans un canapé on peut jouer aux
échecs on peut également depuis peu
voyagé grâce à la réalité virtuelle
comme je vous le disais dans les titres
cette résidence pour personnes âgées de
tuzla expérimenté résultats des seniors
totalement conquis par leur découverte
ils ont par la matiz gardant de la
dépêche du midi horaire dgh la v1
apprécie beaucoup plus parce que c'est
sûr que nous on sait bien qu'on ne
sortira pas qu'on n'aura pas donc il
faut qu'on reste quand même un accueil
l'impression que on a vu quelque chose
ça s'est-il intentions bien veiller
j'avais l'impression que vraiment là les
parties a dit que l'on serait pas ce
n'est pas évident d'être en classe et
d'être un enfant dyslexique alors
regardez ce reportage de vos jeux
télévision daniel rogowicz s'est mis à
leur place le temps d'une journée
harvey
toute ressemblance avec des personnes ne
serait pas fortuite car c'est le but de
cette classe reconstituée par deux
associations de parents dans les vosges
qui proposait récemment à rambervillers
à des enseignants et accompagnants
d'élèves en situation de handicap de
découvrir ce que veut dire être atteint
d'un ou plusieurs troubles dys troubles
du langage écrit par exemple comme la
dyslexie dysorthographie et dysgraphie
qui se manifeste par des confusions et
inversion de sons et de lettres une
écriture lente ou illisibles pour en
prendre la mesure il faut se prêter à un
jeu écrire avec un gant par exemple et
l'âme inverse à sa pratique normale on
peut en sourire mais c'est l'enfer au
quotidien pour les enfants qui en
souffrent ça demande beaucoup de
concentration
c'est pas du tout évident je crois que
si j'étais en classe je rentrais le
tablier au bowling des deux journées là
c'est sûr quinze minutes 6 6 sur deux
jours moi ça ferait longtemps que je
crois que j'aurais quitté l'école là on
est à peu près au milieu de la séance
mais vous allez voir à la fin les gens
sont épuisés rien que sur le secteur de
rambervillers ils seraient 250 enfants
dyspraxiques le terme qui englobe tous
ces troubles dys la science explique par
des problèmes de coordination motrice
d'origine développementale ces enfants
n'ont pas de retard intellectuel mais
sombre souvent dans l'échec scolaire
faute d'une école adaptées à leur
handicap
un enfant qui a des troubles dys sylla
les aménagements qui conviennent oui il
peut rester dans sa classe des
aménagements avec une personne pour les
cd ou un ordinateur la médiathèque de
rambervillers a également investi dans
l'achat d'une centaine de livres adaptés
aux apprentissages des enfants disent on
s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait une
très grosse demande et
triple t'offre finalement temps caen
s'est hissée l'occasion on connaît des
enfants atteints de troubles dys devenue
célèbre bill gates spielberg lewis
hamilton ou agatha christie pour ne
citer qu'eux les association vosgienne
qui se battent pour les enfants et les
adultes 10 car les troubles sont
durables demande juste à l'éducation
nationale plus de moyens et la formation
des enseignants
est maintenant dans ce journal je vous
propose de découvrir l'histoire de sayad
un journaliste afghan qui a fui son pays
qui s'est installée dans les yvelines il
a accepté de se raconter devant les
caméras de célia garçons go et de
bixente mais rien senti steban de tv 78
la chaîne des yvelines
depuis juin 2021 ça y'est de travail
dans cette ressourcerie à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines ici ils
récupèrent des appareils électriques les
nettoie et les revend une activité bien
loin de son métier d'origine sayyed est
afghan à kaboul il était journaliste
pigiste pour plusieurs télévisions
locales il a aussi travaillé avec la
croix-rouge d'afghanistan je fais un
film documentaire medio publicité j'ai
fait un montage aussi mais quand je suis
allé à notre village par le faire à
lever diot par le documentaire je les ai
mon téléphone avec le camra c'était pas
possible parce que l'état les banques
c'est le talent même vu ça
problème pour moi on décembre 2018 il
retourne dans la province de nimroz dans
le sud ouest de l'afghanistan là où les
talibans ils font leur loi il est alors
accusée d'espionnage le début des
problèmes pour sayed espion pour
travailler pour les autres pays donc je
dis non c'est pas vrai alors cassé mon
caméras téléphones après cette
altercation sayed repart à kaboul mais
les menaces de mort continue il est
désormais dans le viseur des talibans le
10 février 2019 il tente même de le
kidnapper en pleine rue sont nés trop
pour sayed le 12 février ils quittent
l'afghanistan en laissant sa femme et
ses deux enfants j'ai fait beaucoup
l'argent pour un programme
externe après iron
et où j'avais un mois de mars mars
2010neuf j'arrive à allemande après elle
m'a
entre agences de réfugiés
pendant cinq mois après son
retour ça y est choisit donc la france
un long périple administratif des buts
il dort sous une tente porte de la
chapelle à paris deux mois plus tard il
rejoint le centre d'hébergement
d'urgence de bonnel il obtient alors le
statut de réfugié en décembre 2020 à 33
ans sayyed attend maintenant que sa
famille obtienne un visa pour venir en
france cachée elle est toujours menacé
de mort à kaboul
un tout autre sujet dans ce journal un
an après avoir pris sa retraite de
footballeur on retrouve loïc peyrat
l'ancien capitaine de l' as st-etienne
en producteur de vin sa cuvée s'appelle
numéro 24 du numéro qu'il portait du
temps où il était sur le terrain de
football il expliqua anthony vers pillon
de tl7 l'intelligent de la loire comment
il en est arrivé là
j'ai eu un beau cadeau de fin de
carrière de la part de mes proches en
fait c'était de venir faire un
assemblage ici à la vie ni facture donc
j'ai proposé à pierre milk de s'associer
sur une cuvée qui serait bas qui serait
vinifié à saint-etienne parce que je
pense que le vin c'est aussi une
histoire il ya le produit forcément qui
à l'intérieur et puis c'est aussi une
histoire une cuvée que loïc perrin veut
100% ligérienne l'assemblage des raisins
est venue de malval sur des domaines qui
font du côte rôtie et du saint joseph un
travail éloigné du quotidien de loïc
perrin jusqu'à présent mais c'est vrai
que ça c'était sympa on allait chercher
la matière première le jus donc avec la
camionnette de permis comme on l'a
remplie dans des des gros en un gros
bidon de
je pus premiers litres ça faisait 500
litres je crois et une partie de sa
reconversion à laquelle on ne
s'attendait pas forcément même si le
capitaine emblématique des verts a
toujours voué une passion pour le vin
malgré sa carrière de joueur pro je
crois que j'ai commencé quand j'ai à peu
près 18 ans alors avec mon père qui
buvaient un petit peu à table et puis en
fait tu commencé à goûter je crois qu'on
a tous commencé comme ça après déguster
du vin c'est pas aussi de se mettre une
grande tollens est
donc voilà ça jamais fait de mal
d'ailleurs moi à mon époque c'était fini
mais je sais que dans certaines mises au
vert dans certains clubs à une époque
voilà la veille des matchs les joueurs
avaient le droit un verre de vin ça
jamais fait de mal à personne en
contraire ça fait plaisir ça permet de
se sentir bien en agglomération avec
modèles toujours avec modération
un vin qu'il faudra garder quelques
semaines idéalement la cuvée numéro 24
ce sera beaucoup les volailles ce qui
est du coup ici une belle sierra qui sur
le fruit les épices douces donc les
volailles sans problème certains
poissons si vous avez envie de casser un
petit peu les codes ça fonctionne les
fromages bien sûr et puis bien sûr le
boeuf mais pas trop de sauce l'idée se
garder je pense le goût du produit brut
c'est un peu l'idée de structurer et se
retrouver le fruit sans trop de matière
de bois voilà comptait 17 euros la
bouteille à boire tout de même avec
modération
et maintenant vous ne parle sport dans
ce journal avec du football et plus
précisément avec le comportement
délétère de certains supporters et
malheureusement de certains joueurs face
aux incivilités la ligue de football
d'occitanie a décidé d'agir détails de
leur plan d'action dans ce reportage de
justin baro pour v occitanie
plaisir respect engagement tolérance
solidarité ce sont les valeurs qui
affiche le club de football de fabrègues
sur ces terrains depuis le début de la
saison pourtant le manager sportif de la
formation amateur constate une montée
des incivilités lors des matchs le
problème des incivilités c'est que
au départ ça commence par des démos et
le moment où ça déborde où il ya des
gestes de la violence ou comme on a pu
voir dernièrement dans la région aux
côtés de marseillan avec la remise qui
se fait frapper qui en vient à dire
maintenant jeunes arbitrerait plus oui
c'est vite et là c'est des choses qui
s'engendre et qui montrent qu'ils sont à
bannir le football une urgence à lutter
contre les incivilités c'est le constat
qu'a d'ailleurs lancé la ligue de
football d'occitanie dans un communiqué
paru le 1er décembre depuis l'instance
régionale met en place un plan d'action
encadré par un référent des actions
éthiques un tout nouveau poste créé il
ya seulement deux semaines aujourd'hui
nous on a renseigné l'observatoire des
comportements c'est ce qui englobe
toutes les incivilités qu'on va avoir
sur le territoire au niveau du football
l'observatoire des clubs aujourd'hui
nous permet de faire ressortir peut-être
trois ou quatre clubs dans lesquels on a
plus de problèmes que d'autres et sur
lesquelles il est obligatoire
aujourd'hui de mener des actions pour
les accompagner ses actions au sein des
clubs avec l'aide des arbitres
d'éducateurs et de délégués font partie
des trois nouvelles mesures instaurées
par la ligue des mesures déjà appliquées
dans certains districts au niveau du
district des p o à thuir en organiser
une réunion entre entraîneurs et
arbitres avec la présence d'un
entraîneur professionnel jean marc
furlan l'entraîneur nagy auxerre qui est
venu un petit peu bas dédramatiser
dépassionner le débat et permettre de
créer un dialogue qui qu'ils soient plus
un à l'image des débordements dans les
stades de ligue 1 le football amateur
n'est donc pas épargnées par les
incivilités le 2 décembre la commission
de discipline de la lega sanctionner un
joueur de 18 mois de suspension pour une
tentative de coups envers un officiel
voilà tout à fait autre chose dans ce
journal vous allez le voir le château de
la roche guyon dans le val d'oise a
encore bien des secrets à nous révéler
mais il faudra attendre sa réouverture
en 2023 après quelques travaux de
rénovation que michaël joly de via 95
nous détaille regarde
du château de la roche guyon le grand
public connaît le donjon le jardin
potager ou encore les casemates
fortifications aménagé par les allemands
pendant l'occupation
mais l'édifice qui a chaud public encore
plusieurs secrets au dessus de la cour
d'honneur cachés par la végétation se
trouve l'entrée d'une vaste pièce
troglodytiques à l'intérieur un
réservoir pouvant contenir 300 mille
litres d'eau un espace aménagé au xviiie
siècle par le duc de la rochefoucauld
au même moment que le jardin anglais et
le jardin potager le château comme comme
tous lieux a besoin d'eau donc il ya ce
réservoir d'eau dans la falaise et créer
en détournant ou en tout cas en
utilisant une source d'eau qui est sur
le plateau à sheikh ans à 4 km de là
dont il ya tout un réseau d'adduction
d'eau qui amène l'eau l'eau y stocker
dans le réservoir et elle vient ensuite
alimenter le lavoir du château elle la
fontaine du village et puis les bassins
du potager fruitier d'un côté et de
l'autre la grande cascade du jardin
anglais une pièce que le château
souhaite ouvrir au public d'ici 2023 une
collecte de fonds en ligne a été lancée
objectif obtenir dix mille euros un
huitième du coût total des travaux à
réaliser pour la rendre accessible
l'objectif c'est de rouvrir un accès par
l'intérieur qui existent mais qui s'est
partiellement reboucher avec les avec
les années donc il faut effectivement
dégager l'accès ensuite remettre le
niveau de sol au niveau où il était au
xviiie siècle parce qu'évidemment il a
remonté depuis et puis ensuite il faut
recréer les ouvertures et surtout faire
un aménagement à l'intérieur pour que le
public puisse y entrer parce
qu'évidemment c'était pas prévu pour
quand
on à le visiter la cagnotte est ouverte
jusqu'au 4 janvier prochain pour l'heure
elle affiche un peu plus de 600 euros le
château compte également sur l'état la
région et le département pour financer
le chantier
et puis pour terminer ce grand journal
on reste dans le sport mais cette fois
ci le sport pour amateurs ceux qui
envisageraient de reprendre des
activités physiques après ces périodes
de fêtes mais qui détesterait la course
à pied est bien il existe la marche
nordique qui présente bien des atouts et
victoria lopez 8 mont blanc suivi pour
nous un groupe de marcheurs plutôt en
forme regarde
on met deux mouvements dans les bras
18h30 près de la rivière du fier annecy
c'est l'heure de l'échauffement pour ce
groupe de marcheurs ils font partie du
club de l'as ptt et pratiquer un sport
de plus en plus répandue la marche
nordique a été créée dans les années
1920 en finlande par les skieurs
finlandais qui à cette époque là
lorsqu'il avait pas de neige pour
pouvoir s'entraîner au ski ont mis au
point cette marche là je dirais que la
technique de la marche nordique vie en
fin de compte du pas alternatif en ski
de fond et donc c'est arrivé dans les
années 90 en france et est actuellement
en pleine expansion après l'échauffement
c'est parti pour plusieurs kilomètres de
marche rythmée ce soir là la cadence est
fixé à environ six kilomètres heure
contrairement à la course à pied la
marche nordique n'entraîne pas de choc
elle permet de développer ses fonctions
respiratoires et cardio véritable sport
à part entière il se pratique avec deux
bâtons un outil essentiel donc le but
j'ai mon bras qui est le long de mon
corps je vais avancer mon bras devant et
dès que je vais devant je vais appuyer
fort sur mondes en plaine du gange l'est
c'est ce qui entoure la main entre
l'index et le pouce ce club compte
environ 30 adhérents la plus jeune des
membres à 28 ans je n'aime pas la course
à pied mais j'aime bien marché alors
chercher un sport aussi à l'extérieur où
je pouvais prendre l'air et sans trop
souffrir la convivialité c'est bien le
maître mot de cette pratique sportive
après la journée de travail on a rendez
vous pour aller marcher en coupe avec un
coach à avoir une dynamique
[Musique]
presque irréelle d'or à l'extérieur
un bien-être la marche vous permet aussi
de discuter donc c'était très convivial
oui le petit groupe se retrouve ainsi
deux fois par semaine pour des séances
nocturnes d'une heure trente dans des
lieux propices autour d'annecy deux
samedis par mois des sorties nature sont
aussi organisés pas de prérequis
particulier pour adhérer l'activité est
accessible à tous quel que soit l'âge
voilà c'est la fin d'un second site et
des territoires merci de nous avoir
suivi sur vos chaînes locales régionales
et sur tv5 monde on se retrouve très
vite pour une nouvelle édition au revoir
à tous
[Musique]